all right people I'm live on the YouTube
it's 8:45 a.m. Pacific here in not so
sunny Los Angeles it's 11:45 a.m.
Eastern on the East Coast and we're
doing these twice a week Direct Message
live streams today we're doing these 20
minute videos today I am just going to
be answering your questions I'm just
gonna share one thought my one direct
message thought of this Wednesday and
then I'm gonna get all to your questions
as a reminder we're only taking
questions at Rubin report com I'm not
taking questions from Twitter I'm not
taking questions from YouTube glad you
want to say hi to everybody
Clyde Clyde come in no I say hi okay
come here
all right there we go all right this is
Clyde everybody you've all met client
already we're doing good here and
lockdown
guys getting good walks and a lot of
good food oh okay so the one thought
that I want to share with you guys
before I get to all the questions is I
wouldn't recommend that anyone ever go
on Twitter right but I would say right
this moment it's a it's a rare lapse in
that because I tweeted out something
this morning excuse me all right I
tweeted out something this morning that
I really think everybody should take a
look at it's a clip of CNN's Chris Cuomo
and he's broadcasting from home and one
of the interesting things right now is
watching all of these broadcasters or
journalists whatever you want to call
them be at home right now with kind of
crappy lighting and whatever makeshift
way they've got to do it and they don't
have their fancy teleprompters and
staffs of 50 people and all the makeup
people and all that stuff there's been a
great equalization of cable news or
general news network news whatever it is
and the YouTube thing and everything
else now we obviously do a pretty high
level of that here because I have a
functioning studio that I could have a
show on CNN or Fox or or HBO tomorrow
excuse me but Cuomo this morning played
a clip of Trump and basically Cuomo laid
it out saying that Trump was lying to
people giving all these people false
hope and then they play this clip where
Trump basically says I'm a cheerleader
for the country and the implication of
the whole thing is that all he did was
tell people good news when they
was bad news on the horizon of course
you're not gonna believe this guys it
was a selectively edited video and Ryan
Saavedra posted the full video which I
retweeted and in the full video you hear
Trump saying I'm a cheerleader for the
country I want people to understand that
there's good news I want good things to
happen to the country but and then they
that's where Cuomo basically stops the
clip and then the next sentence is
basically but we close the border to
China we stop flights from China we stop
from some European countries and then
Trump is going on about some of the
other things that he's done now it
doesn't matter whether you think Trump
has done all this stuff correctly it
doesn't matter if you think he's done
everything wrong
the issue is nothing to do with Trump
actually this is the perhaps bigger than
any of the things that our government is
doing right or wrong at the moment and
perhaps even in a really weird twisted
way bigger than the coronavirus is the
abject failure of the media to be honest
why not just be honest Cuomo and not on
on top of all of that it's like that's
pretty much in any by any standard of
journalism that's pretty much a fireable
offense you are selectively editing
videotape to add commentary to make it
seem like what you said is what happened
when in fact it's the 180 polar opposite
that happened now if CNN had any
journalistic integrity which there's no
reason to think that they do I mean
they've got brian Stelter hosting a show
called reliable sources which if it was
called unreliable sources would actually
make a lot more sense this is this is
embarrassing and it's exactly why every
time I say the word journalists I have
to put air quotes around it so anyway
it's just important for you guys to be
aware of it and I would recommend that
you go on Twitter and look at the clip
because you know for all the people that
only watch cable news they watch CNN
they see that it makes it sound like
like Trump was lying or offering false
hope and then they have no way of
countering reality to that and that's
why this great equalization is so
interesting it's also got a huge set of
problems because we've got big tech that
eventually could just say well you guys
better telling us the truth just can't
be on YouTube and Twitter and everything
else that's by the way why we started
locals calm and why we've got a great
digital community going over at Rubin
Report
all right I want to get to your
questions I literally just saw this one
about a minute before we started the
livestream Bernie Sanders has suspended
his 2020 presidential campaign thoughts
that's from Kevin yeah
I mean good great fantastic wonderful
the ideas of progressivism and socialism
are terrible ideas they have nothing to
do with liberalism there is no problem
that Bernie doesn't think the government
can solve that's the reverse of how I
look at the world I think the government
make basically creates most of the
problems it's going to cause a massive
rift now in the Democratic Party because
the younger socialist radical
progressive psycho basically base and
the Bernie bros of Twitter are not going
to vote for Biden and you see I've seen
some public people say I was going to
support Bernie but now I'm supporting
Trump which seems actually kind of nuts
I mean I get this idea that you're sort
of anti-establishment but like you're
going from socialism to capitalism you
have you're missing a piece of this and
that if it's just because you don't like
Biden well it's like if you sort of
think Bernie's right Biden's a little
bit closer to that Biden has even bought
into some of the intersectional nonsense
which is why he's having trouble
completing a sentence cuz he doesn't
know what he thinks anymore
but the idea that you would go from
Bernie to Trump unless your whole thing
is just screw every mainstream thing
possible
seems like a pretty thin argument but
either either way I think most of the
Bernie people just won't vote I think
the Democrat vote in general is going to
be deeply deeply depressed I still have
a feeling it may not be Biden but more
than anything else again if you vote for
Joe Biden as the president as the
Democratic nominee to be President you
have to know you're voting for his VP
there is no way this guy can do this for
four years I don't think he can do it
right now I mean these these video chats
that he's doing with PBS and CNN and the
rest of it like they're deeply
depressing the guy can't finish a
sentence it's sad I don't mean it to be
glib or anything else it's actually sad
and they better figure out what they're
doing because either they replace him
he'll just say you know I can't do it or
medical thing came up or my family or
whatever and they replace him right
before the convention and by the way
they won't give it to Bernie they'll
just give it to someone else altogether
maybe like an Andrew Cuomo or somethin
else or just know that you are voting
for whatever woman he said it's gotta be
a woman so you're voting for whatever
woman Biden wants to choose or I should
say that the DNC wants to put behind him
let's see can you address this is from
Becca can you address some of the best
actions individuals could take to
reverse the government's covert and do
seizure of power and rights violations
do you think lawsuits after the
quarantine is over will be effective
will be an effective enough rebuke look
the the the two main ones that I'm
worried about are the right to assembly
and right to free speech look we can
talk about the stimulus we can talk
about bailouts and the validity of all
these things and if we ever do them
correctly and all the pork in there and
all that kind of stuff but this idea
that the government has been telling us
that we can't assemble now I've said
this in my interview that's up actually
right now we just posted an interview
with Jeffrey Tucker from the American
Enterprise Institute and we talked all
about this because I wanted to do a show
about sort of what is the classical
liberal slash libertarian tank on
government overreach on bailouts and the
rest of it so it's a great interview
this guy is super super interesting I
think he's one of the clearest thinkers
we've got by the way the videos were all
demonetized by YouTube so thank you guys
for supporting us at Rubin report com
but anyways our whole interview was
really about what your question is there
I'm worried about the right to assemble
because right now you can't you if you
wanted to get 10 people together
technically you're not allowed to do it
now I accept that social distancing and
this six-foot thing is important you
know my family's doing a Passover Seder
tonight where everyone's going to be in
their house and we're just gonna put
laptops at the table when normally at
the table of like 40 people and we're
all abiding by that right and people are
doing this all over the world and many
of you have had Easter dinner you're
gonna be doing that on Sunday and the
rest of it but when government can come
in and tell you that you can't assemble
when we watch
articles being taken off social media
because they run counter to whatever
mainstream media is pushing these are
things that I'm concerned about I'm not
saying that in these extraordinary
circumstances
you can't temporarily to make sure for
Public Safety make sure that people
don't do certain things but we just have
to be wary it's almost like every time
that something crazy happens you know
it's like you don't let a good crisis go
to waste that's what politicians do and
then they sort of test us like in a way
and when I say this I don't mean this at
a conspiracy level I mean this at just
like a mass human level everything that
has happened in the last five weeks
let's say or six weeks it's been sort of
a test could we get people to just stay
in their homes can we get people to not
go to work can we get people to do this
that the other thing and we all
basically pass the test by the way I you
know whether you consider this test a
good test or not you know we're not out
in the streets killing each other right
now there hasn't been rant you know tons
of looting and murders and house
robberies and all that like despite how
crazy this is the amount of people that
have been laid off and the rest of it I
think the best of America has been shown
here the issue and I think this gets to
the heart of your question is that after
this thing can we all step back and
remind ourselves what our rights are
what are those rights in that
Constitution thing in that bill a rights
thing what are those rights to make sure
that they can't be infringed upon and as
I've been saying since the beginning of
this thing I think there are going to be
tons and tons of questions asked both
about our political system our media
system our entire establishment the
institution's all of those things but
also personally do you want to commute
to work anymore do you want to live in a
big city do you want to be so reliant on
these systems do you maybe want to live
in a place where you could grow some
food or be able to protect your family
better or all sorts of things so I think
we're gonna see migration patterns
change I think people are really a ting
their lives you know I posted this thing
on Twitter the other day for the last
month I have been having the craziest
most vivid dreams probably of my life or
certainly certainly in the last 20 years
as an adult something like that and I
posted this and I got hundreds of
responses that you guys are having the
same things that means that our brains
are trying to process a lot of stuff
right now and my belief
and I think there's some dreaming
experts that have you know said this
sort of thing
is that the reason you dream is because
there's a there's a certain amount of
truth and reality and conflicting
information all this stuff that we're
all getting all day long and you can't
process that all day long and then also
function as a person and at night your
brain is just working through a lot of
those things and I think the fact that a
lot of us are dreaming differently right
now and thinking about the world
differently and the rest of it is is
super interesting and it's and it's
hopeful like I'm deeply hopeful like it
seems like we have a lot of problems but
I'm telling you I really believe the
roaring 20s are coming after this the
one asterisk that I would place to that
is if the media so chooses to try to
tank the economy you know that you can
feel like there I feel it I mean even
even I've seen it with some of the
guests that I've had on the show that
that have Trump derangement syndrome you
can feel they feel that there's blood in
the water and they would do anything
they would love to tank the economy if
that's what it took to take out Trump I
mean not only is that it's crazy but
it's deeply on American and everything
else again doesn't mean you have to
think Trump did everything right here or
didn't do anything right and we're not
even out of the woods yet
but I think the media does feel and it's
why by it by the way when I mentioned
this Cuomo clip from earlier CNN is no
longer putting the Trump press
conferences up so they take away the
entire hour long it's usually bout an
hour sometimes more hour long thing
where Trump is talking directly to the
media and you can watch it on edit it
and you can make a decision for yourself
right and instead they show you these
clips that they manipulate so I'm way
more concerned about the danger of that
and again this is very much what my
conversation which every Tucker is all
about let's see do you guys have any
favorite cooking shows your favorite
food blog websites or cookbooks
well so one of the things we've been
doing in the community is we're posting
all sorts of food that we're eating and
barbecue that I'm doing and David's an
incredible chef actually he's working on
a cookbook right now and expanding his
website but in the meantime you can go
to instagram.com slash david's cookbook
and you can see some of the types of
things that we're eating and one of the
things that I've been doing is I've
become really I've always liked a grill
but I've really become a freakin smoking
master
out there so I'm smoking tri-tips and
lamb racks and I've been doing a lot a
lot of burgers we're doing a spatchcock
chicken that's not a dirty word it's
when you take a whole chicken you rip
out the spine you kind of butterfly it
fillet it and and Grill it we're doing
all and then smoke it too we're doing
all kinds of cool stuff so and by the
way tons of you guys are posting your
food pictures too and that's actually
what I'm more interested in right now
I'm more interested in what are you
doing to potentially better your life in
the midst of this thing are you cooking
more or you're gardening as I said are
you doing more exercise you eating right
in general what music are you listening
to all sorts of stuff let's see have you
thought of running for office this is
Wayne mayor or mayor of LA or even
governor I mean I can't say that I've
never thought about it but I don't think
it would ever happen the machine would
have to be so different than it is you
know look I'm able to say what I think
here I'm able to communicate with you
guys and you guys can communicate with
me and we can share something and I
think I'm a pretty decent communicator
of ideas and that's why I like doing
this that's why I wrote this book that's
coming out in a couple weeks the idea of
becoming a mayor in LA or or governor or
even a senator like that doesn't appeal
to me I could see some situation like 20
years from now maybe when I retire and I
really just like disappear altogether of
trying to become like the mayor of a
small town that I live in and just
trying to help at the most local like
community level possible the big thing
is not really for me though I could see
something perhaps you know Candace Owens
has now said that she's gonna be running
for national office it's unclear whether
it's gonna be senator governor or
whatever there's always rumors that
Shapiro could run for something or I
guess some of the other people that um
that I'm in circles with I could see
some situation maybe where I could be a
press secretary like that actually kind
of seems fun and interesting to me like
you know you've got the president or the
governor who whoever it is and then
you've got the media and the press
secretary is the guy between those
things who has to communicate ideas who
has to answer the questions I think I
have a good handle on on the nonsense of
the media
so I can see something like that but I
think I'm doing the best thing that I'm
supposed to be doing right now
we all know how you feel about Star Wars
this is Devon but I'm genuinely curious
what your thoughts are on Lord of the
Rings you know I think I just need
robots
I need robots I need space I need some
sci-fi I like dystopian future stuff I
like lasers I like spaceships all of
those things I don't really love that
other medieval thing so I didn't really
love the movies I didn't I've never read
the books I I didn't really love the
movies I know they're good I know not
only do I know they're good but I'll
make a major concession here I mean Star
Wars especially the last three the lore
of it and the ethos behind it
he's so wrecked and confused and messed
up that they've really just mangled Star
Wars to a point where it's interesting
as far as I know they haven't even
announced the new trilogy yet you know
they're doing some one-offs but it
really tells you that they really like
they've completely lost the plot as it
were so Star Wars is a freaking mess
right now which is very depressing
Mandalorian was fine I didn't think it
was spectacular but I need a little
force I guess and there you know there
was a little baby of course but I need a
little more force than that but my hope
is that at some point now they're gonna
be able to reset Star Wars into
something that that makes sense and not
every time they're about to give you an
emotional moment to take it away like
they did in the last movie which was
actually the last movie was fine JJ just
had to clean up so much garbage that
Ryan Johnson did in the last Jedi but
then every time there's an emotional
moment you think Chewbacca is dead now
he's not dead
you see you think c-3po never has has no
more memory in effect dead as a robot
then he suddenly has memory again you
think what's his name Finn is gonna die
several times he keeps coming back and
the one before that you think that that
a Poe is gonna die he comes back so
every time they give you an emotional
moment they take it away and that's
highlighted more more than anything else
by in the last Jedi that moment when Rey
and kylo Ren they're in the palace you
know in the Red Room right after they
kill Snoke and they're on the same team
and you're like holy cow has the light
in the dark come together this totally
flipped the script on Star Wars this is
new and interesting
and then by the end of the scene they go
their separate ways so the Star Wars
just got all sorts of mangled but yeah I
just don't love the The Lord of the
Rings I'm gonna this is sin win I'm
gonna ask you one of the most difficult
questions on earth Tupac or biggie
you know I mean honestly I don't know I
like I like Frank Sinatra I listen to a
lot of Dean Martin my all-time favorite
of course is is Frankie Valli I should
have been born in the 40s so I could
have just been listening to music in the
50s yeah we'll leave it at that
what was your first job you had as a
teenager great question so I was a camp
counselor like a day camp counselor for
for a while and that doesn't really
count as job my first job like when you
think of a teenage job just like crappy
job oh and I i delivered newspapers in
the neighborhood but I worked at a
really dumpy drugstore in a mall try to
picture a Long Island mall like a
drugstore why is there a drugstore even
in a mall and you know I was basically
like a stop boy and I had basically all
day long I would have to go to the
shelves and you know if people picked
out a few things you got to move the
stock up so basically I just spent a
summer just moving the stock up you know
moving little hair products up moving
the toothbrush up moving the the floss
up the lipstick and all that it was it
was pretty it was pretty terrible it was
pretty terrible but it ends up being a
happy story because right across the way
from that mall drugstore was an
electronics boutique which you kids out
there may know it's Game Stop although I
guess game stops not doing too well
either these days but at the time it was
known as Electronics Boutique and it was
a video game store and I was obviously
huge into video games Nintendo Sega
Genesis the whole thing and I ended up
my first job out of college was I don't
like to brag but I was an assistant
manager at Electronics Boutique in
Broadway mall in Hicksville Long Island
and I moved as I always tell my friend
Colin Moriarty back in 99 I move more
red Pokemon for a Game Boy than anybody
okay we could not keep them on the
shelves
I moved Pokemon like nobody's business
and I actually really
did enjoy that job but you know it's
like anything else if you start working
in something you love you suddenly see
the underbelly of it and it's not as fun
or sexy and you start hating videogames
and the rest of it oh there was another
question here actually about videogames
so I've got this PlayStation 4 over
there in the other room and you know I
have no frickin time but I've been
trying last night I tried it again to
just find a few little moments here and
there where I could play something for a
few minutes and I'm trying to play with
my with my brother and my two childhood
buddies and my nephew so we just
downloaded we all got gauntlet something
Slayer Edition I think it is it's $4.99
on ps4 I think it was a PSP game and we
got headsets and we just haven't even
been able to coordinate a time but I
have played that for a little bit it's
mindless you just get to crush stuff and
then smash things and jump around that's
what I like that's what I like I tried
to play battlefront us last night and
it's like I just can't I can't do it I
can't run that way I can run that way I
could run that way but I can't run that
way um okay let's see oh that question
by the way about Nintendo that was
Esteban in Mexico City hola amigo let's
see
did you watch Tiger King it's freakin
hilarious we watched the first one and I
actually fell asleep I I have the real
issue in life about if it rolls around
to like 9 o'clock or so and we start
watching something I rarely rarely can
make it to the end like if I'm on the
couch I can I can be up and productive
and working all day long every day from
the second I wake up until until the
night but once I get on that couch and
we start saying I have a hard time
waking up I will tell you this over the
weekend we rented the hunt which was a
really really interesting sort of a
throwback to 80s action movies but it
has a really insightful twist on sort of
Trump supporters in the media and the
liberal elite and everything else I
won't say any more in the map but I
would recommend that you check that out
it's just kind of fluffy sort of more
eighties action bloody bloody as hell
nonsense but you might want to check
that one out and the other thing that
we're doing right now is we started
watching The Sopranos from the beginning
so tonight we're at the last episode of
season 2 of The Sopranos and when I
watch The Sopranos originally I
started in season three so as of tonight
I will be caught up to where I was and
it's sort of interesting watching a
great you know really robust interesting
in-depth series from the beginning and
especially when you've missed parts
because there's been people that I know
aren't gonna make it and people I know
get whacked and I know other things that
happen who cheats on who and who kills
ooh and the rest of it so I've been
absolutely loving that I've been
thinking maybe when we're done with this
if we stay in quarantine that maybe we'd
restart Battlestar Galactica because as
I said I do like the robots all right so
I know there's a bunch more questions
here and I will what I've been trying to
do is cuz I can't get to all your
questions now during these 20-minute
live streams I'll jump in the app or on
the desktop version at Rubin report comm
and I'll give you some text answers to
these things also a couple quick updates
we now have a full content library at
Rubin report com so like this today when
our clips with Jeffrey Tucker or
demonetised you can now get the full
episode and the clips and free at Rubin
report comm and that's really how we
support the show because YouTube is just
a crazy landlord so we we built a home
that we that we own we're also going to
have text chat which I think is
launching next week we're also working
on live streaming and a couple other
really cool features and we're building
something that I actually really do
believe is internet 3.0 that everybody
whether you're a politics guy or a
talker or a gamer or a knitter or a nun
boxer or you work at a non-profit or at
a synagogue or a church or a mosque or a
local sporting community whatever it is
that digital homes for communities are
the future and then they will figure out
how to communicate with each other and
we do that on the back end where you can
create your own networks with other
like-minded people and all sorts of
interesting stuff so we build something
really cool with locals calm you guys
can sign up your own locals community if
you're not a creator per se you can join
other people's communities there's no
trolls and BOTS cuz it costs a couple
bucks to get in there's no deep
platforming because all the creators
create their own set of rules so if I if
you come into my community to just raise
hell I don't want your money I'm gonna
boot you out but you haven't been deep
platformed because you can be in anyone
elses Locals community I think it's a
mature decent way of looking at the
internet from bottom up and not asking
big tech or the government to solve all
of our problems and all right
considering I just
woke up 45 minutes ago I would say this
was pretty productive I'm gonna have a
little sip of coffee here you guys have
a great day I look forward to continuing
to to talk to you over at Rubin Report
calm and just stay sane in the midst of
all this there is a silver lining we're
all going to get through this thing
together I've no doubt about it and for
those of us that are awake as opposed to
woke right now I think we have an
opportunity to to help usher in
something really cool after this and I
hope that you will join me and being a
part of that all right have a great day
everybody